I know that Julian Assange early
WikiLeaks has done work I guess exposing
corruption in the Kenyan elections and
so forth and so on but I will not be
convinced that Julian Assange is just
for transparency wherever he finds it
until he does something like this that
would be as damaging to the Chinese or
the Russians or the Iranians or
something like this at this point I
think I just would call him an
anti-american activist
julian assange is a diluted anarchist
who has managed to give the world in the
American people a largely valuable
glimpse at the history of what its
government is done in the war on terror
in doing that Julian Assange has also
placed in danger brave Afghans and as
ares and others who have helped American
diplomats and American intelligence
professionals and American soldiers in a
very serious war against Iranian
proliferation against the Taliban and
against al-qaeda I believe strongly that
what is done in the name of the American
people needs to be understood clearly
and transparently by the American public
if there were limits with respect to
violations of the Constitution American
law even some moral or hypocritical
betrayal on the part of the
administration deception line willfully
the use of American policy in a way that
fundamentally contradicted the
administration's public line all of that
it seems to me would be fair game in
this in this game of exposure but I
cannot and I'm a trained historian I
cannot be on that like it strikes me as
entertainment and entertainment for the
sake of entertainment when in fact
serious issues are at stake is a huge
problem it's a scattershot approach to
disclosure I don't think it fits neatly
with WikiLeaks self-declared mission
which is to combat corruption to promote
government accountability etc etc all
those noble goals I think the this
collection is very diffuse often very
interesting I think researchers will be
scouring over it for years and decades
to come it's a really unique
action but it also comes with some
negative consequences for the conduct of
diplomacy for American sources and
interlocutors abroad and worst of all I
think it's going to have a back lash
effect on information security policy
secrecy disclosure and so on from a
solace perspective you know what I think
is is fascinating is his idea that he
sort of used this from a systems theory
perspective and that you can use this to
overwhelm the system and I'm not
actually sure that's true in so far as
I'm not sure there is enough of a I'm
not sure the system is as coherent as he
thinks it is and therefore it's not
vulnerable to attack in the way in the
way that he that he thinks it is it's
hard to say what the effect is going to
be uh you know the question will will
diplomats be less discreet I think
diplomats that work AG are going to
remain kg I think that diplomats from
nations that our friends of the United
States are going to find a way to
discreetly share information
intelligence cables in the intelligence
relationship between the CIA and other
intelligence services really hasn't been
disclosed in this in this data dump but
it's again it's difficult to say I think
that relationship of the reset so to
speak with Russia is going to be very
badly damaged the private views of
people like defense secretary gates that
Russia is an as basically a security
state it's not a democracy I think that
is something you've already seen a
public reaction from Vladimir Putin
combine that with how we are learning
now of Russian perfidy such as it's
dirty war against Georgia that started
in 2004 according to the Georgians and
the assessment of the US ambassador in
2007 I think you will also see that
there will be less patience I think you
could say in the political class in
Washington for reaching out and
pretending that Russia is is is
cooperating so that's one area where you
could see some damage I think also it's
out in the open that China
tax people that doesn't agree with in
the cyber realm this is something that
the that the Bush administration and the
Obama administration had been loath to
say in public because there is so much
you know join equity between China and
the United States well that's out in the
open so this adds some more data points
about the complexity of the relationship
with China and proves what a lot of
people thought China's a frenemy the
long-term implications of it are going
to be very very difficult to tease out
because while you know as I say I don't
think it's going to cause sort of a
visible collapse of any kind of system
anywhere in the next six to 12 months it
is just it's another accretion on the
weight of how we try to do how we try to
do non-military business between nations
and it's another kind of weight around
our ankles for four Americans first and
foremost but really for everybody in
terms of it being another impediment to
having genuine trust and genuine ability
to work together in the way that
diplomacy in either its 18th century
model or its 21st century model assumes
that you can that you can bring people
together across nations to function
4shared self-interest it's like you know
in subatomic physics if you observed
something you change its its state and
so I think when you disclose these
records you also perturb the system now
you may perturb it in positive
constructive ways you may motivate
foreign officials to stand behind the
views that they privately proclaimed or
you may motivate them in the opposite
direction you they may feel they need to
distance themselves from what they told
you privately to demonstrate that oh I'm
not a hypocrite I I never was going to
do what the Americans said that i said i
was going to do and so the act of
disclosure has diplomatic and political
consequences may be good may be bad
can't really be predicted in advance and
so it is a it's a there's a recklessness
involved in the act of disclosure I
think counterpart X in capital y is
still going to want to talk to the
American
ambassador the station chief and the key
senior reporting officers at the embassy
because he's got a case to make to the
United States he's going to want to make
it and very effective and often
tantalizing terms that's not going to
change I think our allies will still be
our allies and our enemies will still be
our enemy so unbalanced I'm trying to
figure out you know are these just
footsteps on the sand on the beach which
will be washed away by the next wave or
is this some kind of more durable
sandcastle that's going to have a more
lasting impact on on foreign policy I I
can't sort this through right now
nothing anybody can but it's I'm really
hard pressed to see how this is going to
change much it may alert the
administration to more effective
security procedures you know there's
been an effort over the last decade to
to limit and reduce the amount of you
know basically taking stuff off the
front page in new york times and
classifying it that will now be reversed
more stuff will be classified top secret
and code word which would have kept it
out of of this channel the fight to
declassify old cables you know you still
have to fight our intelligence community
very very hard to declassify 30 and 40
year old cables that will now get harder
rather than easier so so many of the
effects this is going to have on secrecy
I think are going to be quite bad at the
same time it seems clear to me that if
in the past the trouble we faced in
American democracy was that it was too
easy to keep things secret and there was
a certain tyranny of you know inability
of the elite to terranize in that way
now we're going to have a sort of the
tyranny of the tyranny of data points I
have to say I think there is great
potential in the original WikiLeaks
concept of providing a secure mechanism
for the disclosure of wrongly restricted
records that reveal misconduct
corruption and so forth I think that's a
an idea whose time has come it's
technologically feasible in a way that
it never was before
as necessary or more necessary than ever
before in terms of the you know the
health and character of the world's
regimes there's an urgent need for
greater transparency I think they've
sort of fumbled it with with their you
know their the way they've executed the
project